so that's from the academic community or
a subset of the academic community what
about from the public
so for example i imagine that there i
know gary gets this i know many people
get this plenty where there's there are
the people who consider themselves to be
the rational skeptics were
the rational skeptics of the sort who
only follow where the evidence leads
them and this is all woo because there's
such a paucity of evidence and you're
believing people based on testimony and
that's not what one does in
in science and it's not replicable etc
and and and partly that's true but then
the dismissal of it i don't agree with
the deriding and the
and the snide remarks to come along with
that so did you were you on the
receiving end of any
of those
oh definitely i think that a lot of
people will say that
it's
you know
i mean let's take the rational
you know the approach that this is not
rational in my opinion that's completely
rational like if you're seeing things
and you're getting results let's take
this the space program our united states
space program and the russian space
program as an example of this okay and
when i say an example of this what
an example of
um basically people not following the
evidence okay so the evidence is this
that the people who founded our space
programs did a lot of weird science
woo science i would call it woo science
and they still continue to do that tyler
is an example of somebody who's doing
weird science you can't replicate what
he did with jack parsons who founded our
space program
uh werner von braun founded you know he
was german but he came over to our space
program um and then um constantine
tchaikovsky he founded the russian space
program all of these people created
the calculations that would get us off
of earth right that would get us up into
space okay well that's
big okay
and they did this through means that
looked
irrational they had techniques that they
used and as a person who studies
religion these are identifiable
techniques these are body techniques so
they're using a lot of
what we would call
you know like eschesis that's a greek
word for
um
almost like becoming um very very
disciplined with respect to
your
lifestyle and your mind and your
thoughts so they were going into some
kind of uh almost like an altered state
of consciousness at least jack parsons
was
and then creating these you know kind of
downloading this information
um well
what what does that say um i just
recently given a talk and i made this
case i said that's where the data leads
us i mean if we're rational we're going
to say yeah you can't replicate that but
that's where the data says that those
things actually work like those kinds of
you know um i spoke to carrie mullis
here i'm gonna
i don't know if you can hear that can
you hear that no no no oh okay never
mind then um
all right carrie mullis he is a nobel
prize winning winning chemist right so
he is uh he discovered the polymerase
chain reaction all right
now
i suggest to your listeners that they go
check out his webpage carrie mullis
where he talks about he died two years
ago um but he basically talks about
creativity and his means of being
creative was exactly like tyler's means
of being creative and very similar to
the space program you know people in
space program and he's a genius okay and
so what i'm saying is this i'm not a
scientist but i'm saying to scientists
the data looks
weird right it looks weird but i think
it and it looks like you know these
people are doing things that are not
rational but to a person in my field
these things are actually
patterns and why would you ignore those
patterns if they're giving these amazing
results
if you're actually you know if the
results
are something that you would you know
you want why discount than the
body practices that they're engaged in
that's my point and so i think that is
actually rational
there's there's rationality to the woo
let's put it that way
so what if someone says okay the fact
that these practices exist and then
instigate some creative or that spur
some creative insight it doesn't mean
that
what they think is occurring is
necessarily occurring or is objective
and many creative people have practices
that are deviating and peculiar even
newton he engaged in alchemy and let's
imagine that alchemy served as the
inspiration for calculus it doesn't lend
credence to the objective validity of
alchemy it just means that just like wim
hof can say that hey you may have a
creative insight if you run for a while
then jump into a cold bath maybe that's
true and there's an extremely tight
relationship between our body and our
our minds and it doesn't necessarily
mean that
they're
even if it's consistent consistently
when you jump in that bath consistently
when you perform alchemy consistently
when you meditate in this way and and
supposedly talk to beings and so on even
if that's the case it doesn't mean that
the mechanisms that you think are
working are the reasons it just means
the practice work
i totally agree with that yeah i'm on
board with that in fact i would suggest
that that's what we that's the type you
see to to me you're thinking like a
person in religious studies
you're saying there are patterns here
and the patterns have to do with some
body practices right excuses body
practices but this body but the body
practices are different for each of
those people and they're kind of strange
like if you took jack parsons he did a
lot of really weird things i would not
want to have hung out with him right so
you know he's part of some you know
aleister crowley and people like that i
mean frankly very very different than
constantine tchaikovsky who does very
similar ritualistic things but they have
they are in no way does he view it as a
new form of religion you know he thought
of his as christianity so do you see
what i'm saying and then when tyler's
doing it here in the you know 2000s
he's doing very similar things
but he's not he doesn't think of it as
aleister crowley he would he would be he
would probably be horrified to even
think that it had anything to do with
jack parsons right so what i'm saying is
i agree with you entirely i think that
what we need to do is we need to
identify that these people do these
things and what are these things and are
there patterns yes there are patterns
but what they specifically believe about
them is based on their own interpretive
framework so jack parsons happened to be
in la in the early 20th century where
there was a belief system in place for
him to kind of hook into
if you look at do you know ramona john
the mathematician okay he thought that
the goddess lakshmi was whispering those
calculations the math calculations
brilliant math genius into his ears so
that was his interpretive framework you
see what i'm saying um also i when i was
doing american cosmic i was reading up
on creativity and um i forgot the name
of the um the person whose work i had
read but she was really she's really
good um and it's it's there's it's cited
there in american cosmic but basically
she said that if you do if you look at
the brains of people who are being
extremely creative we're talking about
creative genius uh what you see is that
something is shut down i think she said
in the executive lobe or something like
that the executive promotion is shut
down and the people that are being
creative are attributing their
creativity to something objective
yeah so they're attributing it to
something objective that doesn't mean
that there's something objective there
it just means that that's what they're
doing
right and so i that's the way i would
like to do this research and that's how
we can avoid you know a lot of people
are are just they have knee-jerk
reactions to it for some reason like
that's woo you know well it's weird that
works and i want to know why it works
that's basically my position